alo alo
[âm nhạc]
có một câu khẩu hiệu hay một câu riêng
của mình để kiểu thay vì cầu cho các bạn
quen thuộc Thực ra nọ không phải quen
thuộc nữa Nó kiểu kiểu bình thường
ấy nên có một câu gì đó
riêng nếu mình muốn muốn về sau muốn một
cái một cái gì à thương hiệu riêng đúng
không Thì nên có một câu khẩu hiệu riêng
à một câu gì ạ slogan à không biết dịch
ra tiếng Việt là gì
slogan
campaign đ thử nghĩ xem quả slogan
kiểu riêng của mình nó như
được cả tiếng Việt nhỉ Chắc thế
có những yếu
à kênh này
à target audience Ok Ok nhầm nhầm
community tức là cộng
đồng đam m c hệ
ừ những người trái anh muốn học it
sao tích hợp một con ai chatbot và Đ nhỉ
có khó không không Tôi có một con Lama
không biết con Lama là gì được trên sẵn
không biết đọc tà tài liệu tích hợp arel
như thế nào Ừ ở công ty tôi đang dùng
con chbt tích hợp vào bạn chất là nó
cũng gọi ai à Gọi api các thứ thứ thôi
Tôi không nghĩ là nó khó tích hợp thậm
chí là đấy ông dùng luôn hẳn một C dùng
hẳn chity kiểu hỏi cách tức hợp vào như
nào thế thực tế là tôi từng tích hợp vài
cái con chatbot rồi tôi gọi đến api nó
xong rồi nó phản hồi lại thôi Không
không có gì khó đâu không ạ Nếu ông làm
quen với api rồi
sức
sống
à gì nhỉ khích lệ tinh thần à gì gì
không gì
cháy đốt cháy for t unlist your
inner qu thế
live à cho
slogan cho thương hiệu cá nhân
hướng đối tượng là dân
ở Nhật trình hoặc đam
mê công nghệ
này
ừ
à gì à
sologan nên mang tinh thần à Tôi đang
dùng nick của công ty nữa không Không
chơi cái này
được dùng đăng nhập và nick
khác mà thôi kệ nhỉ Chắc chẳng sao rồi
mang tinh
thần khích
ra là cái Google Dịch này cũng làm được
cái cho đấy
mà tô tắt xử cái tiện í Google dịch
rồi cái tiện Google dịch làm được
mà
chẳng qua tôi ấn nh chẳng qua tôi
không
này tôi tạm tắt đi rồi
chứ
nhy như này tạm tắt đi
công nghệ tự do mã hóa đam mê genz sức
mạnh trin soi
kết Ôi buốn
trái tim của Uầy câu này hay đỉnh mãi Ui
tôi sẽ lấy câu này
được
ui phải đăng stus Câ này luôn mới được
chất
quá solo gầ của
mình mấy ông không được chơi bản quyền
không nhá toàn bộ Cái này thuộc về tôi
đy Đợi tí đang status đã đang status
nhanh không phải bị ăn c bản
nhanh hơn nào
chưởng ngay kiểu ngầu ấy cho dù rõ toàn
là không
kiểu ngầu
[âm nhạc]
tương lai câu này đệp khúc
tình bạn đ không buồn
đờ Ừ có kênh đấy chưa nhỉ nghe hay
đấy được tâm sự
coder tâm sự
coder có nhóm này đu không ạ nhưng mà
cùng coder Chắc chưa mình chơi xong rồi
mình lấy lấy tên username đấy tâm sự
coder Nhưng mà thực ra lại
là mình cần code
app cer của
Tâm xem
mẹ hay đ
hôm trước có hai bạn hỏi cái
này nếu mà ông nào chưa biết có
link link điền form Câu hỏi thì
ờ cái link mà Tâm sự ấy đúng nhở tôi để
cái mô tả
nó sẽ bao gồm cả kiểu form để điền câu
hỏi trong đấy để các bạn có thể Điền câu
hỏi
nhá Thì đầu tiên thì về cái chuyện hối
trước từng có người hỏi tôi học rốt toán
học rốt máy môn tự nhiên như th này thì
có học lập trình được không học kèm
tiếng Anh học lập trình được không em
chẳng thích muôn nào cả vì có hợp lập
trình được không đấy kểu Thế thì N Thì
đại khái thì thì ờ thứ nhất là nó vẫn là
học đúng không ạ Nếu mà một khi mà bạn
đã cảm thấy là bạn ghét việc ngồi trên
trường học thì bạn nên ngồi ở đâu đó học
còn nếu bạn nói là bạn ghét học ho học
cái dị không thấm vào đâu
thì thì tôi nghĩ là bạn phải bỏ bỏ cái
sự nghĩ việc ghét một cái gì đó tôi nghĩ
là thế bởi vì tôi thấy đa số số nhiều
người à Ghét một cái gì đó vì cảm tính
kiểu dạng Nói chung là cảm xúc mình chứ
không phải
là thực sự là kiểu người ta không phù
hợp với cái đấy ví dụ ví dụ nhá Tôi vẫn
nhớ hồi trước tôi từng có một hời tôi
rất khó chịu Cô Giá tiếng Anh cái này
tâm sự à một tí tôi tôi nhớ cách Bây giờ
tôi cách kể chuyện này nó sẽ n ná giống
như là anh jvi evermine một tí vì tôi
Tôi cảm thấy là cách nói chuyện tôi bây
giờ bị ảnh hưởng với anh ấy khá nhiều
nhưng mà câu chuyện có thật nhá Không có
sao chép gì cả
thì đầu tiên tôi nhớ là có hai câu
chuyện của tôi hồi cấp
ba về
kiểu cô giáo gọi lên
B một lần một lần thì hồi
đấy hồi đấy Kiểu tôi tôi là người kiểu
dạng là tiếp xúc tiếng Anh cũng khá là
sớm từ bé th kiểu là nghe nhạc nước
ngoài nhiều đấ à Nên và xem phim nước
ngoài các thứ Tuy là không hẳn là kiểu
biết rõ nó lắm đâu bập bõ bập bõm thôi
nhưng mà Bởi nghe nhiều ấy thì mấy ông
dễ thấy kiểu không bị Sợ gì mà không
thấy quen ấy
đấy nên là tôi cảm thấy cũng tự tin nên
là tôi không đi học thêm tiếng Anh của
cô ấy xong rồi Đương nhiên là cô đấy là
một người tôi cảm thấy là kiến thức
chuyên môn của cô đấy không tốt luôn Tôi
vẫn nhớ chính xác r có lần tôi để ý là
cô ấy có một quyển học tiếng
Anh kiểu nâng cao ở trên bàn Cô ấy Tôi
nghĩ là cô ấy vẫn phải cần học thêm ý
hiểu thế
à gì nhỉ ờ cô đấy vù dập tôi một cách
kiểu rất là kiểu công khai cả lớp đều
biết ví dụ một điển hình nhá À cô ấy mời
một bạn sinh viên lên à Một bạn học sinh
lên bạn
đấy làm một bài ở trong trên trong sách
giáo khoa làm một bài tầm 10 câu vẽ làm
được bảy câu có cho bảy điểm đấy rồi đến
lúc gọi tôi lên mấy anh em của tôi ở
dưới Đã bảo thôi xong rồi lại đến giờ
rồi đấy Xong rồi cô gọi lên bảo tôi làm
một bài Tôi làm xong bài Cô đúng hết cô
bảo được nhỉ Xong rồi làm thêm bài nữa
xong rồi bài nữa bài nào cũng 10 câu nhá
đấ làm thêm bài nữa vẫn đúng hết đấy cô
bảo Ôi khá nhờ xong rồi bảo làm lên bài
thứ ba bài thứ ba tôi sai một câu Soo B
tưởng thế nào tôi cho s điểm đi
xuống
k lúc đấy thì rõ độ Vừ dập
luôn cả th lúc đấy rất nhiều người lắc
đầu kệ chấp nhận đấy hồi cấp ba tôi cảm
TH
tôi khá là ghét tiếng Anh vì kiểu đấy
Cái người dạy cho mình nó Tác động lớn
như thế nên tôi cũng hiểu được là đôi
khi tầm quan trọng của thầy cô rất là
quan trọng thế nào nó làm ảnh hưởng đến
việc là mình kiểu mình thực sự muốn học
hay không đôi khi là đôi khi không phải
do do bản thân mình đúng không do chính
thầy cô kiểu tác động vào nó một phần
lớn nhứ đúng không Đặc biệt
là đặc biệt là nhều lúc mình còn không
xác định được học cái này để làm gì mà
đúng không học đôi khi là đúng nghĩa là
mình học vì bố mẹ bảo thế vì thầy cô bảo
thế vì xã hội đều làm thế chứ thực ra
mình không hẳn mình Đam mê nó sẵn nên
thành ra là chỉ cần có thêm những cái
yếu tố tác động kiểu nho nhỏ như thế ảnh
hưởng tâm lý mình mình chán học Mình
không muốn học Mình học
kém Nếu mà có yếu tố như thế thì các bạn
cũng phải nên nói chung là các bạn phải
hiểu rõ được nguyên nhân là tại sao mình
học kèm với môn đấy đã Nếu mà giả
sử Giả sử nhá Nếu bạn học kém mấy cái
môn ở trên trường vì năng lực của bạn
theo kiểu
là không không phải là mấy cái môn tự
nhiên thì chắc chắn thường có một vài
môn không phải liên quan đến học thuộc
mà gần như là nó sẽ chỉ liên quan đến
logic đúng không Thì bạn phải đúng là
bạn phải cải thiện logic bởi vì Làm lập
trình đúng là cần logic và cần tư duy
nhưng
theo tôi thường hay nói là không cần
phải tư duy quá Thiên Tài tư duy cao
siêu gì cả thực C chỉ cần là tư duy
của tư duy của một người bình thường là
đủ rồi Tại sao lại Phả tư duy của một
người bình thường bởi vì các bạn phải
làm ra phần mềm mà nó hoạt động như một
người bình thường muốn nghĩa là mình
mình làm mình không nên làm một cái phần
mềm chẳng ai dùng được đúng không chỉ
thiên tài mới dùng được được không Mình
là phần mềm mà người người thường dùng
mà đúng không Thì mình phải suy nghĩ như
mà người thường mình suy nghĩ là kiểu
bấm vào nút này người thường sẽ hiểu
được là à Nó sẽ hiển thị ra cái này Đấy
mình làm được như thế Thế là được rồi
còn nếu mà siêu hơn kiểu bấm và mút này
nó còn tự động một cái gì gì đó làm
người dùng bất ngờ đấy Kiểu thế thực sự
là người dùng không biết được mình cần
cái đấy nhưng hóa ra là khi làm xong thì
người dùng à Nó có thể làm này hay nhở
các thứ nhưng người dùng vẫn phải hiểu
thì rõ ràng là vẫn tư duy của một người
dùng bình thường đấy chỉ cần bình thường
đủ không cần phải cao siêu không phải
thiên tài quá Tôi đã từng dùng những cái
phần mềm thiên tài quá Như thế thành ra
rất là khó để dùng các thứ cũng như là
các bạn mở code nó phức tạp quá các bạn
lập trình The kiểu Viết đoạn đấy ngầu
quá xong xịn quá chẳng ai đọc hiểu được
cả thì cũng không ổn đúng
không nên là tôi Tôi nghĩ là cái việc
học kém ở đây nếu mà bạn dựa vào việc
năng lực là logic tư duy nó không ổn thì
đúng là mình phải cần Lại cải thiện cái
đấy thứ hai đó là nếu mà học kém mà do
là việc là bạn không chịu học thì không
chịu học cái gì Chẳng có gì dỏi cả mà
cái thứ ba đó là học kém là do là bạn
học nhưng mà không nhớ kiểu dạng
là dễ quên này hay là hay sao Nhan mất
tập trung này thì cái đấy thì bạn cũng
phải tự cải thiện thôi bạn cải thiện
bằng nhiều cách ví dụ là thực hành nhiều
để nhớ hoặc là giống như tôi tôi biết
Thừa khả năng đọc tài liệu của tôi tôi
nói thằng là kém tôi không ngồi trau rồi
đọc tài liệu được và tôi tôi còn chỉ nhớ
không đến nỗi tồi nhá Tôi công nhận chí
nhớ tôi không không nỗi là kiểu Ừ tệ lắm
nhưng mà tôi sẽ có nhiều cái tôi sẽ
không phụ thuộc vào trí nhớ của bản thân
mình bây là thời đại công nghệ rồi cái
gì mà mình kiểu ghi ghi chú lại khi ghi
ở đâu đấy để mình nhớ mình lưu lại ở rất
nhiều cái ứng dụng để nó nhớ hộ mình ấy
thì lưu lại thì cái lập trình này mình
bản chất Mình chỉ cần nhớ từ khóa rồi
mình tra lại tài liệu hó tra Google bây
giờ Có cả ai tra hộ mình nữ cần tốt thì
mình không cần phải nhớ nhiều nên là là
nên là cái việc đọc tài liệu mình có đọc
nhá Nhưng mà mình vẫn nên học cách đọp
lướt và đọp sằng lọc không cần phải
không cần trí nhớ quá tốt trí nhớ giỏi
nên là tôi nghĩ
là lập trình nó không bị B bây giờ ấy
tính ra bây giờ đó lập trình không hề
khó như Nhiều người nghĩ nhưng mà đang
nói vẫn bài toán là lập trình có thể lập
trình Còn về việc là ông muốn làm lập
trình Lương đến nỗi nghìn đô hoặc là
thậm chí hơn theo kiểu là tiền sâu hơn
rất rất sâu vào ấy thì nói thẳng là càng
ngày nó càng khó Đến cả bản thân tôi Tôi
không tự tin được là về sau tôi lên cái
mức kiểu rất là senor hay Master gì cả
Bởi vì tôi cảm thấy là tôi cũng cái đấy
nó phải yêu cầu rất nhiều yếu tố hơn
thì tôi thứ nhất là bây giờ lương của
tôi được như bây giờ cũng được tính là
một
xio và tôi cảm thấy là tôi chỉ được đế
thế thôi tức là ví dụ ví dụ nhá Giả sử
xo ví dụ nhá Giả Sử C là lương 1000 đô
chẳng hạn đế 2000 đô chẳng
hạn thì tôi nghĩ tôi chỉ được căng nhất
là thế thôi đấy
tôi còn nếu mà bình thường ở các công ty
khác lương của CEO có thể tăng lên cà
càm tăng dật các thứ các thứ ví dụ Thậm
chí các bạn có nghe vụ xo có thể lên đến
4000 đô các thứ chưa tôi tôi thấy cái
chuyện đấy cũng không hề mới rất là bình
thường thì tôi không phấn đấu đến cái
mức độ mà kiểu kinh khủng như thế bởi
lúc làm thế thì trình mình rất là giỏi
và mình phải cầy rất là nhiều cái việc
là mình phải chuyên sâu rất nhiều cái
nữa không phải mỗi full stack đâu mà
phải biết đép ốp và các thứ các
thứ Nếu thế thì tôi không phấn đấu đến
cái con đường đấy tôi vẫn sẽ dãy sang
làm kiểu về database với Chắc là chỉ
database thôi và code back end kiểu
chuyên chuyên như bây giờ thôi và về sao
chuẩn qua đi Dậy chứ không định hướng là
kiểu cầy cầy cầy biến thành Master bởi
vì nghĩ là mình không lên được cái mức
độ đấy nghĩa là mình biết giới hạn bản
thân
được câu này bạn ấy một cách cũng tương
đối rồi anh chỉ giúp em phần cơ sở dữ
liệu phần đơn vị
tính Tôi không biết đơn vị tính như Win
max là như nào
À chắc là trong hóa đơn bạn ấy có ghi à
Có nhiều đơn vị mỗi đơn vị có nhiều giá
trị cái này chắc em phải ví dụ cụ thể
hơn anh đang chưa hình dung được này em
thể inbox inbox anh
nhá th ra hôm nay tôi định tâm sự có rất
nhiều cái ở đây tôi lưu lại để tâm sự
mấy ông chư mà mình tâm sự tận hai nể
ngồi trả lời Tận 20 phút rồi tâm sự 10
phút nhé xem
nào không nhớ cái này cái gì cơ
xem tiktok về bị rảnh quá đi ngồi lớt
tiktok không ạ thông cảm
nhé Ừ cái này hay này đừng để cột bên
này n thử zoom lại xem không bị mất
à
xem đã xong rồi tôi cho tâm sự sau vậy
Ừ Chắc cái này để sau đi
Ờ n Hôm nay chắc là nhảy sang code Mấy
hôm nay không ngồi code rồi thực ra mấy
hôm nay không ngồi code cho mấy ông xem
chứ thực ra tôi vẫn tính tính ra hôm
trước tôi bảo đấy Kiểu sau mấy cái hôm
tôi ốm dậy tôi code cũng được nhiều
em nên dùng tư duy code nhiều hơn sử
dụng II
một cái gì đó cả thì phụ thuộc tự nhiên
mình sẽ bị kiểu mình sẽ bị mai m kiến
thức hay là tốt hậu các thứ thứ nhưng
mà như vừa nãy tôi nói đó là kiểu Tôi sử
dụng Google khi mà tôi chỉ cần nhớ từ
khóa tôi tra được tài liệu các thứ thứ
sử dụng ai để nghĩ hộ trong một vài bài
toán thực ra cũng được
nhưng mà không phụ thuộc ở đây là bản
chất là là mình phải hiểu được nó code
như thế nào nó n ná giống như là kiểu B
trước khi có ai đúng không Ông tra mấy
kết quả trên Google xong m ông copy cái
đoạn code đấy về gần như là cái đoạn
code đấy có có thể là nó chạy được luôn
cái mục đích của ông cần thì có phải vốn
dĩ vốn dĩ
là vốn dĩ là đoạn đấy Ông không cần phải
nghĩ không thế trước đấy trước đấy trước
khi mà có stack flow hay các thứ chắc là
mọi người cũng à Lúc lúc mà mới có cái
đấy chắc là mọi người cũng nói đừng có
phụ thuộc code ở trên Google à đừng phụ
thuộc code trên các thứ tự nghĩ ra đi à
đúng không Tôi cảm thấy là
ờ
À cái mấy cái này nó sinh ra làm đúng là
đúng nó sẽ làm mình lời hơn và kiểu nó
có thể khiến mình bị phụ thuộc các thử
thứ nhưng mình vẫn phải nghĩ là chỉ là
mình vẫn phải học từ mấy chính cái đoạn
code đấy mình không nên copy code về
xong rồi chạy được là xong mình không
quan tâm việc là thực sự nó nó có tối ưu
hay không nó chạy kiểu dạng nó có thể
xảy ra được cái bức gì không vân vân
mình vẫn phải hiểu được cái đoạn mình
làm Còn nếu mà chưa hiểu ấy thì nên từ
từ hiểu Và thậm chí là bởi vì tôi làm đế
cái ngưỡng này rồi tôi cũng hiểu được
kiểu code nó sinh ra các thứ thứ đấy tôi
vẫn hiểu được à Tại lý do tại sao nó làm
như thế nên là tôi còn nói cho nó để nó
sửa lại đoạn code đấy nữa nên tôi hoàn
toàn cảm thấy là tôi đang không hề bị
kiểu kiến thức bị yếu đi qua ai đương
nhiên là tôi bị Phụ thuộc nó hơn gần đây
Tôi công nhận bởi vì cũng lười hơn mà
nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy là nó như nào nhỉ
tôi vẫn công nhận thường hay công nhận
tôi là một người lười à lười đây là lười
lười rất nhiều cái nhưng tôi không lười
nghĩ đấy tôi khẳng định điều như thế nên
là khi mà tôi Lười thế tôi thường hay
kiểu tôi Làm lập trình này cũng và tôi
đam mê Cái lập trình này cũng chắc là
bởi vì tôi lười bởi vì sao phải có rất
nhiều thứ việc lặp đi lặp lại tôi không
muốn làm việc lặp đi lặp lại thế Tôi
nghĩ rồi sẽ làm ra một cái tool gì đó
một cái phần mềm gì đó để nó tự động làm
hết hết cho tôi kiểu nó tự động những
cái gì tự động được Nó những cái gì lặp
lại thì nó sẽ tự động đấy thì có phải rõ
ràng là cái nghề của mình nó sinh ra để
khiến mình lười không đúng
không nên nên là thôi không nghĩ là việc
là ai khiến mình bị ảnh hưởng lắm mà do
chính mình quyết định điều đấy hơn bạn
copy code về không cần dùng ai nó vẫn là
sai thôi nó vẫn là kiểu đi học kiến thức
từ người khác và học mấy cái bạn áp dụng
những cái thứ Bạn đã học th nó cũng một
phần là thế thôi
mà quan trọng là như tôi vừa nói tổng
kết lại vẫn là bạn học gì từ ai các thứ
thứ
nhỉ Không không dùng cái ai assistant
này lắm là
thôi Đợi tí xem nào
được đồ án tốt nghiệp để giá trường chứa
anh nếu mà dùng Cái đấy để làm ra trường
nó hơi bị yếu quá Nếu mà thật sự là là
cái độ án để tốt nghiệp thì anh nghĩ là
cái phần web nâng cao ấy gọi nâng cao
Thực ra nó à Đâu không phải nâng cao mà
chuyên sâu ấy thì em làm hẳn cái đấy nó
sẽ xịn
hơn bởi vì lúc mà anh dạy sang cái đấy
thì nó là cái độ án hai nó bài toán nó
nghiệp vụ phức tạp
thì mình đang làm dở đến
Đế phần sản phẩm đúng không ạ
này đó Kiểu kiểu dạng là bấm vào đây thì
có vẻ là toàn bộ thông tin
nó điền được vào đây thôi Còn mấy chỗ
này thì ra không điền được thì bây giờ
tôi sẽ sửa lại cái đoạn
này cái phần
option này Đợi tí Đợi tí đến cái phần
đầu tiên là cái thumbnail này
này vẹ hợp lý
Đúng rồi bởi vì cái ảnh ở đây đợi thìi
ảnh đây thì mình sẽ cần cái đường
link ảnh nó của mình là cái gì
ra là cái cái này tôi vừa rồi tôi cũng
quên mất cái đường l ảnh của mình đang
lưu ở đâu thành ra cách
đó là mình nên tạo một cái heer để mình
lưu lại được à à Mình lưu lại ảnh ở
trong đâu đấy và
lúc đây Mình lưu ảnh ở trong
đây edit thă lại ở đây lại là cái đưu
trong product mà nhỉ Đợi tí
ra được ảnh này
nhá này à nhm img
Này
Thử đ thử
Ồ xịn nhỉ Bây giờ tôi mới biết đấy Đó là
tuy là mình lưu Mình lưu lại vào trong
mình lưu lại và trong cái đường dẫn này
đúng không mà không thấy mà đúng không
lêu hẳn ở trong đường dẫn này như
này Thế mà lúc truyền như này nó vẫn ra
được ảnh Uầy Cái thằng larel làm cơ chế
này kiểu gì
Thế có sợ bị trùng tên file ảnh xong rồi
nó ra một cái ảnh khác không
nhỉ
thôi Đang sợ kiểu như thế kiểu hai thằng
trùng tên
file ra sử Ánh khác đương nhiên là mình
để như này chắc là ảnh nó sẽ biến thành
tên nó thành kiểu unic một cái gì đó như
này nhưng mà nó vẫn có thể tỉ lệ trùng
mà đúng không Mình chia là nhiều thư mục
rồi mà tự nhiên bây giờ gõ như này ra
được một cái này tức là đồng nghĩa việc
là nếu có hai ảnh trùng tên nhau
ví dụ
nhá đây tôi thử Bây giờ tôi biết bộ này
không ạ mới thật đây rõ ràng nằm trong
thăm product các thử thứ là no
nhá Này Thăm product này có một cái ảnh
nào đó ở trong
này nó nó có tên là như thế đây ảnh này
tôi thử đổi cái th new
trung nhau đúng không
lỗi tôi lỗi tôi cái tham UR này mình
mình đang lưu Mình lưu cụ thể đường dẫn
nó dài dằng giặc cả cụm này quên mất chứ
nó không Tôi tưởng nó tìm ra được đây
Mình chỉ lưu Mình chỉ cách nhau với cái
storage này thôi thực ra
cái trong thăm này Mình lưu cụ thể cái
đường dẫn của cái file ảnh rồi Ok
ok ừ thế này chống cũng
xuống dưới chứ nhỉ đúng
không Tôi xem
có thì
mtib đây
này sẽ bắt trước cái ở
có thì sẽ hiển thị rất nhiều ảnh thì ở
đây đợi tì edit
Ok query ở
đây mình lấy tất cả option đây có lấy
lấy cả product inmate mà nhỉ nằm trong
admin product controller
này đây bên admin controller rồi
với ít MT phải nó sẽ not empty à Thôi
không rõ về mấy cái hàm này lắm
có hay ngược lại
đi emt nh
đúng hay không nhưng trông rất là
tính là nối tiếp cái chuyên sâu hay
không Nhưng mà đại khái nó là
ờ tại nhên
Ừ Nó là một cái dự án thực tế để mà các
bạn thể xem học hỏi thôi Không tính là
chuyên sâu hay
lúc mà chọn cái này Lúc mà chọn cái
upload th này này à đâu Lúc mà chọn cái
upload upload image này này thì nó gọi
đến đây click xong rồi làm gì tiếp
read ul xong rồi appen như thế
này vào à đâu à Đây cái này empt rồi ok
sẽ xóa đi Sau đó thì pen inmate các thứ
thứ vào qu là
được cũng là một cách nhưng mà ý anh là
là kiểu
luôn Được cái ul có thử thử cũng hay
kiểu gọi là ul review review chẳng
nhỉ Xem
à quên chắc thì đã theo cái gợi ý thằng
này đúng xem cái database bằng này đã
lừa
lắm bảng này sẽ product inmate này colum
này đy
quả đặt tên nó thử lng nhằng Ok không ạ
à Xuống dòng
ơ Br rồi mà nhở Mà thôi kệ đi không về
bài toán giao diện mình tính sau đó
nghĩa là nếu mà giả sử mình ấn edit thì
nó sẽ ra cái kiểu như này đúng không
dưới như này cơ Hay mình sẽ để kiểu như
này
nhỉ Ừ
kiểu để hiểu được là là có thể chọn
replace để thay đổi nó
cái khác Bấm vào để đổi sang cái khác ý
tôi như
thế chắc là sẽ hiểu thôi đúng
không Ví dụ Giả sử chọn như này đổi
này chọn chọn như này
Đó ok không ạ Cái này nó cách nhau bởi
cái gì
đấy hình như HR hay gì ở à Br rồi HR và
sao Br Br HR
Ok mình lại bắt trước vậy
Br
trông thực ra không đẹp lắm mấy ông kệ
Kệ về khoảng giao diện đi ạ
Ờ content
nhỉ Hay là cái này nó đang là nun à Hay
là đang bị xám h rồi
nà À đây
không lưu được
ờ đúng rồi Có khi là mình không lưu được
cái nội dung của bài đăng
ạ Có chứ em Có
chứ mô tả đấy mô tả có vẻ không đúng rồi
nên c tiếp
nào hân hạnh tài
trợ chương trình
rồi chơi cái ảnh kiể này thật khó cốp
để
nhỉ Hay là bây giờ nó làm kiểu mới kiểu
như này để cho nó tránh copy
rồi ảnh kiểu này trông hay mà
đây Ok rồi đấy Xong rồi bây giờ thực ra
không thể bấm lưu được vì
mình bấm lưu rồi là xóa t bộ option
thị toàn bộ option đây
đã đây có dữ liệu t body đang trống bây
giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra lại set tiếp nếu mà
có đúng
không
cái đoạn này Thực ra nó phải ghi như này
này làm bị xống dòng mất cái tex Arrow à
không không xuống dòng mình kiu này chắc
không xuống dòng vì bản chất là nó nối
liền nh
này ghi kiểu này
thể tham khảo kiểu này của pp8 đó là họ
chấm kiểu này nó bằng optional Tức là nó
sẽ không báo lỗi nếu mà cái biến này nó
không
không kiểu nó là nun không được khai báo
luô như chắc chắn lỗi
như này luôn kiểu như này tiện rất nhiều
đấy xịn
không
pp8 hỗ trợ C này
sai sai phải để thử
cứ bị sợn
năng trong cho team thì cần phải xây
database trước Hà mọi người không chính
xác không phải S V trước mà phân công
trước mọi thứ
chứ
Ồ anh list của em trước đây Xây dựng hệ
thống Google m ngấu
value đợi t đợi
t option có
option nó phải product option này mới
đúng
chứ xong rồi ra được option đ đợi Đợi tí
đợi
khi truy cập một thuộc tính của mod đồ
dùng Magic method nên p stom luôn cảnh
báo Ờ anh thì dùng cái tiện x tiện x id
id heer để nó tự động generate ra cái
đoạn comment ấ để cho ppst không không
cảnh báo nữa hoặc chến giả Em có cách
khác em tắp sư đi cũng được không cần
khai baáo cá set kiểu kinh khủng quá
đâu
cái option này phải quay lại một tí code
logic bên này có option này lấy ra key
này Mình lưu lại product option Kể như
này mình lưu lại giá của từng cái key
value đúng
nó sẽ đợi đợi t tắt cái này
bên này là ớ Đúng rồi
này tự nhiên đúng không định Ấy À đúng
rồi sửa đây nó không có key có value nh
value lại không đúng lắm Đợi tí Đợi tí
val này không
đúng đúng nhở à đâu có đúng thế là đúng
rồi đấy nó sẽ đến mức option Xong rồi
đến name Ôi xịn nhỉ
này cái này cũng nằm trong select
là cái này là mấy ông thấy là nó sẽ Giả
sử tôi a thêm mới một cái m không sẽ
thấy khác
này chuẩn nó sẽ là kiểu như này đúng
không ạ n nó sẽ phải đề xuất tất cả các
option đây và mình select một cái thôi
thì ở đây mình làm như nào mình bản chất
là mình
cũng bản chất
là Nhưng mấy ông thấy Đây đang
là x select option thuần Còn đây là V
select 2 thì bởi vì cái này generate ra
nó đều select 2 rồi thại sao cái này lại
có ID
nhỉ Tôi có để cái này ID gi nhỉ ớ Để này
ID à Ừ thế là sai đấy nó phải class nó
hợp lý hơn để này Lỡ để này ID
đâu
tiếp theo nà class nó phải class như này
chứ th sao để nó ID
nhỉ
tí click 2
select 2 chứ À quên trang này mới
điểm Hồi trước tôi bị dính quả này đó là
m không thấy à cái cái này nó bị thay
đổi với cái kích cỡ ạ bởi vì cái này
liên quan đến kích cỡ của cái ở bên
trong nữa và mang tiếng là mình dùng
class form form control này nhưng mà nó
vẫn bị ghi đè lên bởi class của riêng
thằng này bởi vì nói thẳng luôn là là
cái c nó không còn dùng cái input này à
đây không phải input nhậ nó không còn
dùng cái class của cái thằng select này
bản chất cái này đâu còn là select đâu
Xem x bản chất nó cái gì đây nó thể span
các thứ thứ này này nó sử dụng class
riêng của nó không dùng cái class của
form control nữa nó bị ghi đề lên Nên là
Hồi đấy tôi vẫn phải căn thiệp bằng SE2
bot
Chat đấy Kiểu như này kiểu ghi ghi đè
lên và dùng cái class à class riêng của
nó kiểu Style riêng của nó đợi tí đợi
tí
các thứ thứ Còn không thì dùng hẳn tham
à
chap đấy nó trông như này cơ
đấy ông sẽ phải có cái này cài thêm vào
để team bo chap như này
nhỉ
n khai báo đâu
vậy muốn tất cả cùng dùng chung cái này
khai báo đâu không
nh hoặc là để để để tôi thử ghi cái này
ở đầu đầu nha xem được
không hiy vọng
router Model biding thì em phải khai báo
cụ thể rõ ra như này
này
Ừ Bình thường em khai báo thì em kh khy
báo rõ ra như này hai chấm rồi to Ken
như này chẳng hạn thì biết ở lấy cụ thể
cột gì còn không là sẽ lấy mặc định cột
cột khóa
chính vẫn lệch à tại sao vẫn lệch đ nhỉ
Hay là do khai báo của mình thế này chưa
đúng để xem nào
cái font control này
đây đợi tí sai vãi
chưa chữ lại bị bé thế kia nhỉ Ủa
được sử
đầu nghi ngờ rất nhiều cái
i mình không muốn ngồi sửa giao diện nữa
đâu
revert revert code revert code revert
code thức là tôi nghĩ là để cố định luôn
được chẳng cần phòng control Cá thứ thứ
phải để cho giao diện điện thoại dùng
mình có zung bú chat nhưng mà code để
cho kiểu viết CS được được rồi chứ không
phải để giao diện điện thoại để dùng
chẳng ai lên đây để ngồi chỉnh sửa cái
đồng đấy cả đó đẹp rồi đúng không
ạ xịn đ không
xịn th chứ đúng không Đấy xong mình copy
cái đoạn này vào như này
Đấy Bây giờ mình ấn X thì bản chất là
mình cần lưu lại được cả những cái cũ
này tức
là Nếu mà có truyền lên thì mình ghi đè
vào không thì thôi chắc là được thử
nhá đ tí D kết đã đề phòng nếu mà lỗi
thì không sao còn Copy lại dễ
bùm h onun yeah lỗi rồi xem lỗi này tôi
nghĩ là lỗi
này đúng rồi Đây cái này
này thì ở đây là nếu
có í thăm Nếu có truyền lên thì mới nhận
đúng không ạ vứt đến đây Đấy
xong chạy thực tiếp nào
chạy phát nữa xem nhanh không đó nhanh
vèo tôi tải trang này trang bên này giữ
nguyên nhá tải trang này xem mất gì
không Yeah mất cái này rồi Đúng rồi
Đương nhiên mất bởi vì rõ ràng vừa nãy
mình đã sửa cái đoạn đấy đâu
mình muốn có chữ content ở đây
mà thấy không Mình ở đây nó sẽ
description chả sao để đây content luôn
ạ đình thật đấy
tận à rất nhiều người xem Em hôm nay
không tâm sự gì cả mày ngồi code thì ít
người xem hơn không sao tôi chấp nhận
tại trang đó Ok xịn chưa ạ Ổn chưa ạ Đó
bây giờ sang hẳn
trang trang sản phẩm này nhá tài lại đây
đó xịn chưa ạ được
nhỉ cái này nhìn trong giãn dòng Cái này
nhìn trong bết quá
Xem Tại sao lý do bên này trông xấu
xấu như này luônn Ờ nhưng
mà thôi ngại sửa CS quá không biết sửa
CS thế nào nên tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ kệ cái
đoạn này
Ừ tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ kệ đoạn
chọn mấy cái này đã chứ tôi sẽ phải requ
ở đây bắt phải chọn mấy cái này
và chọn mấy cái này đã thì mới được thêm
mào giỏ chứ không không đểm màu sắc kích
cự kích thước cho vào giỏ Ok mấy bạn đã
thấy tôi làm xong tương đối tương
đối về cái kiểu dạng nhà trông xịn mà
đúng
không anh em nào thấy đóng góp ý kiến gì
ngoài giao diện nhé Ngoài giao diện nhá
thì mấy anh em cứ đóng góp nhá nhưng là
tôi thấy trông cũng gi Rì đúng
không quan trọng là nó còn trông kiểu
dạng Mấy ông có hình dung được không ấy
hình dung kiểu là như nào nhỉ nó dễ dùng
hay không ấy tôi tôi thấy là nó cũng
trông cũng không thấy nỗi mà nhở đúng
không đi nội dung nội dung các thứ thứ
này sẽ đẩy
tạm dừng đây đã hôm nay Tuy là làm Có vẻ
hơi hơi ít tính năng nhưng mà cha để
buổi hôm sau tôi sẽ
ngồi trình trưởng sửa nốt thêm mấy cái
này thử đặt Master layout đi anh đ Xem
Uầy bây giờ mình thấy một loạt câu
thấy metronic với view C
template chưa biết cả hai cái đấy không
biết thế nào Cái nào admin đẹp hơn ạ bên
admin thực ra có một sự thật bên admin
thì không nên quan tâm đẹp quan tâm V
kiểu nó gọi là như nào Tối giả
và dễ dùng đừng quan tâm về màu mày đẹp
thôi từng có một thời Quan Tâm màu mày
đẹp xong rồii cùng thì sếp tôi đ bắt đập
đi bởi vì cảm thấy nó quá màu mẻ nó kiểu
quá bị rối mắt ấy đấy ít màu mẻ thôi tối
giản thế là
không biết làm theo từ đâu Ờ em Chắc là
phải theo dõi từ playlist từ những cái
buổi đầu à không phải không phải ngồi
xem nhưng ý là kiểu em em phải biết lập
trỉnh cơ bản Xong rồi đến nâng cao một
chút đã thì em mới cảm thấy là anh làm
mọi thứ nó dễ hiểu hơn còn không công
nhận khó thật xem mấy xem mấy buổi đầu
xem mấy buổi trước thì chc ra cũng được
mà vì tính ra tôi vẫn tương tác với các
bạn với Vẫn kiểu có live chat này tôi
thấy cái vụ live chat này rất là hay như
lúc mình cảm tưởng giống như mình không
học một mình đâu mấy cái video họ tự học
ở trên mấy cái nền tảng khác ấy nó không
có cái vụ live chat ông khi ông học Ừ
thì nó sẽ tập trung hơn đấy Hiểu dạng
kểu mình mình với đống khóa học thôi mà
nhưng nó sẽ bị kiểu chán ý và kiểu có
lúc mình thắc mắc kiểu chẳng thấy ai
giải đáp chẳng ai giả đáp hộ mình và
không biết là có có những người cũng
đồng cảm với mình cũng thắc mắc như thế
các TH thừ thứ mình bị khó chịu ấy việc
học qua YouTube này tôi thấy Tuy là có
thể là đấy ví dụ Giả sử là có nhiều bạn
tôi biết là không a
à Không xem video kiểu trực tiếp như này
mà Bởi vì họ không thời gian hay vân vân
họ bấm vào xem lại
à kiểu à xem mà lúc khác ấy thì họ cũng
kiểu cảm thấy là cũng có một cái đội
tương tác nhất định qua cái live chat
này cá nhân tôi tôi cũng thế Tôi thường
anh xem tôi có thời gian để ngồi xem
livestream của một vloger hay là của
game đâu nhưng mà tôi xem tôi xem lại
rồi tôi xem live chat nó hay phết kiểu
cuốn phết kiểu à đến đoạn này phải kiểu
kêu gào cổ vũ chẳng hạn đấy có nhiều
người kiểu spam kênh chat giống mình đấy
mình cảm thấy bui lay
tôi đang hơi ôm tí nên tôi phải giữ sức
khỏe một tí mà nên thế V tính ra tôi cốt
cả ng Mà buổi hôm sau tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ
ngồi cầy Nếu có sức thì sẽ ngồi cầy lâu
hơn với mấy ông thế nhở ui hôm ny thứ
năm rồi Tôi cứ tưởng thứ ba tôi lại định
bảo buổi sau tức cả thứ năm sang tuần
hiy vọng sang tuần sẽ ổn hơn đấy thô còn
cái kèo mà anh em còn đi Tập thề dục
cùng nhau nữa đấy Nói chung là tôi tôi
rất là Hảo hứng cái Kèo đấy Kiểu cảm
thấy là giống như là mình có một cái
cộng đồng gì đó kiểu một nhóm nhỏ anh em
với nhau cùng nhau phát triển tốt lên ấy
Hay
một tí về cái cái vụ
à tối ngày mai nếu ông nào ở Hà Nội thì
qua btis à Tôi có đăng cái Kèo đấy Ở đây
Nói chung là mấy ông thì hoạn đi ý keo
phát Đấy Gala âm nhạc đấy btis mấy ông
có thể tham gia cùng btis là nó là học
viện bư chính Vĩnh thông ở Hà Đông
ấy à quên nó không phải nó là của Bitis
Nhưng mà không phải ở đấy mà gần hơn nhá
nó ở đâu thì ông vào đây ông Xem cụ thể
sẽ rõ
nữ sinh phết tôi th Lần trước tôi qua
đây
thức hoạc động của nó và database dựng
như thế nào Anh nhỉ cái này nó vẫn không
thể trả lời kiểu ngắn gọn được đ tiên em
cứ tạo th ở bên discord Xong rồi xong
rồi ghi rõ là em muốn nó nó như thế nào
Và nếu có ví dụ càn tốt ví dụ kiểu em
muốn một cái tương tự như Messenger em
muốn tự một cái tương tự như Zalo hay là
telegram hay vân vân em phải càng nói rõ
chi
tiết thì mình mới biết đ triển khai được
vì có rất nhiều ứng dụng Chat bây giờ
nhưng mà mỗi thằng nó chắc chắn nó sẽ TH
kế khác nhau Nó sẽ có gần như là nó còn
gọi là đi sâu về những cái mảng khác
nhau nữa không thể thiết kế một cái
database một cách kiểu có thể áp dụng
được trong mọi trường hợp được nó bị rất
là bị rối rất là khó mình chỉ nên đi vào
một cái cụ thể thôi càng cụ thể mô tả
càng cụ thể càng tốt và có ví dụ hoặc là
cảm thấy là em muốn có một cái nó vừa
tích hợp cái hai thằng này vừa tích hợp
cái hai kia và Vân thì như thế nào thí
ra người ta dễ hình dung được để còn
phân tích là là database của thằng này
thì nên như th này database thằng kia
nên như nào đấy em tạo THT ở trên
discord
nha Ok
Ờ buôm nay chắc là tạm ngừng Ở đây có gì
thì hẹn anh em vào tuần sau nhá À anh em
nếu mà tiện thì thích nghe tâm sự thì
ngồi kiểu xem qua mấy cái video đống này
buổi sau tôi sẽ tâm sự về cái đống này
Chào mấy ông